significa esta llegada del ejército ruso
a bacmut en que cambia el curso de la
guerra
Bueno lo que demuestra es que el Grupo
Mercenario ha sido eficiente y ha
cumplido con las tareas que de una
manera u otra
ha diseñado o dispuesto el Green porque
no es el ejército regular ruso quien ha
estado allí presente y es una modalidad
que nos recuerda un poco
ese recorrido histórico desde la época
de los condottieri donde se han ido
prevaliendo de tener grupos que pueda
realizar la labor que le tocaría en ese
momento al ejército regular
y precisamente la llegada del ejército
regular en qué va a cambiar la batalla
la guerra
se supone que el ejército regular pueda
ser más eficaz Además de que da una
especie de simbolismo de que no es ya un
grupo Mercenario sino que es un ejército
regular que responde a los intereses del
país es una situación un poco ambigua a
final del camino lo que debemos nosotros
analizar Es que esto es una guerra y que
esto no no es más que un eufemismo de
una manera u otra un grupo como Wagner
como han sido grupos en su momento como
Black water no es más que la
privatización
de una de las acciones más antihumanas
que es la guerra entonces lo que se
busca de una manera u otra es disfrazar
que allí También hay rusos que son
ciudadanos rusos no importan que sean
domiciliarios o personas que también
pertenecieron al ejército ruso yo creo
que a final del camino a lo que
asistimos es a un cambio en cuanto a la
modalidad de presentar algo tan terrible
como es la guerra y en otro de los
episodios de la guerra que se ha
conocido hoy Rusia y velaruse ya
afirmaron el acuerdo para desplegar las
armas nucleares tácticas en su frontera
Alexander lucasenko ha dicho que ya ha
empezado este traslado Qué significa
este movimiento qué va a suceder es una
mala noticia aparte de todas las malas
noticias que estamos teniendo con
relación a la guerra quizás estamos
todos tranquilos en nuestras casas sin
pensar que este conflicto todavía no se
ve una actitud de parte de la de las
partes involucradas en llegar a un punto
de inflexión que se pueda hablar de paz
y donde hay una potencia nuclear como es
Rusia y más el traslado de esas armas
estratégicas nucleares a Bielorrusia no
es más que un anticipo de todo el
entorno en el cual se encuentra la
humanidad en una guerra que
evidentemente nos afecta a todos